My name is Wei and
I'm here together
with Kiegan, who is down
there getting miked up and.
Today, we're going to
talk to you about bees.
So bees. We think R users have
a lot in common with bees.
For one thing, we share
a love of hexagons.
But more importantly,
bees are pollinators.
And we know is that the
pollinators, the pollinator
population, is really important
to the health of an ecosystem.
And I just notice we have this
beautiful backdrop behind us
with these really
nice butterflies.
So not we didn't plan this,
but it's kind of appropriate.
And what we hope to convince
you of by the end of our talk is
that like bees, R users can
enrich their own data ecosystem
with effort and empathy.
So what do we mean
by data ecosystem?
And to explain, I
think it's going
to be helpful to tell you
a bit about ourselves.
So Kiegan and I work at NORC.
We are a nonpartisan social
research organization.
And at NORC out coworkers,
our partners, our clients,
we work on, we use
different types of software.
So SAS, Excel Stata.
And we produce lots
of documentation.
So policy briefs, technical
reports and data code books,
and we do that in a variety
of formats, like Word and PDF.
We work with expert coders, non
coders and everyone in between.
As R users and developers,
we have to leave the hive
and we have to interact with all
these people in our ecosystem.
And to do so, I think
we're very lucky to have
all these great tools that
folks in the R community
have built to help to
facilitate these interactions.
So so that's what we
mean by an ecosystem.
It's a diverse environment
where we have folks
with a range of skills using
different types of software
and creating different
kinds of products.
Why do we feel so strongly about
enriching this data ecosystem?
Well, three reasons.
So in our work, we either
succeed or we fail together.
So if our work is late
or we bust our budget,
the client is not going to
care that the R team did
this or SAS test
team didn't do that
or many review took two
weeks longer than expected.
So it's really important for
us to make sure that everybody
succeeds, whether we are SAS
user or a Stata user or non coder.
The second thing is,
well, as R users,
we do better work when
others do better work.
So it really helps us
when others thrive.
And the third thing is
that the low the more we
can lower the barrier to R for non
R users and beginner R users,
and the more we can
show that R not only works
with other software, but it
also works for other software,
then it's easier for us
to convince our bosses
to invest in the
infrastructure and to support
R and other open
source software
and also to pay for us to come
to this conference next year.
So so that's why we care so much
about enriching the ecosystem.
Before we dive into
how to be a pollinator.
So just one word about
what we mean by empathy.
When you when we
work in an ecosystem,
you quickly realize that
different people
have different ways
of thinking about the world and
biologists have a word for it.
It's called umwelt and
an umwelt is an animal's
perceptual world.
So every species senses the
world in a different way.
So two species sharing the
same physical environment
have completely
different experiences
of the same environment.
So bats and whales, for example,
they hear the world in a world
that human beings do not.
Here is where empathy comes in.
So among all the
species, humans are
unique in that we
have a capacity
to appreciate the
umwelt of other species.
So in our context,
empathy means being
able to perceive code and
perceive data in a way
that other people do.
Now again, I'm going
to share with you
three lessons we've learned
on how to be a pollinator.
And the first lesson
is do no harm.
As R users and developers,
it's really important for us
to be really careful and
intentional when we interact
with others in our ecosystem
and when we deal with
foreign data formats.
So so here is one example of
reading data from Stata into R
and they say that the lessons
that stick with you most
are the ones you learn
from your mistakes.
And so this is one that's
near and dear to my heart.
Anyways, this example comes
from the General Social
Survey about GSS and GSS
is one of the most widely cited
studies of American society.
It's a study that's been run
by NORC for the past 50 years.
And here we have an entry
from the GSS codebook.
This variable
describes the number
of education received
by the respondent's mother.
And the codebook tells
us what the unique values
of this variable is and number
of cases with each value.
And then at the bottom, we have
this section reserved codes.
Right? And these
are missing values.
So there are three different
types of missing values.
And we have 316 cases
that are missing value
because they said
they don't know.
And then we have 100 cases
that are missing values
because they said
that they did not
grow up with a female
caregiver growing up.
So they were not
asked this question.
Now when we read
this data, data file
into R, we see that the
three different missing value
types have been collapsed
into a single NA. Right?
And this looks bad, right?
Because it looks like we've
just lost information.
So so what do we.
Well, why this happens. If folks
are familiar with census data,
is that whereas
these two software
have extended
missing types so they
can support multiple
missing value types, R only
has a single system missing.
Right so so what do what
do we do about this?
Well, it turns out that the
R data object that we have,
whether we've read in
the data using haven
or we used the foreign package,
that R data object still
contains these
missing value types.
Right? And it takes a
little bit of effort
and a few more lines of code to
recover the different types.
Folks who are interested can see
haven's conversion semantics vignette.
for more information.
But our point
here is that when you're working
with a new or foreign data
format, it really is
important to take a moment
to learn about
the idiosyncrasies
of that specific format.
And it's part of doing no harm.
Here is another example.
Here we have a screenshot
of an Excel spreadsheet.
The contents don't
really matter,
but you can see that a few
rows have been highlighted
and so there is data
in the formatting.
And these could be
cases that have been
flagged by a team for review.
So some people have feelings
about formatting as data,
but our view is that this
data can be important,
and it's important that
we preserve this data.
The great thing about R
is that these packages,
openxlsx, tidyxl
that really helps
us to retain this information
in a very easy way.
And we should take the
effort a few lines of code
to preserve this information.
So the lesson here is it's
going to take a bit of effort
and a bit of empathy.
But it's really
important as pollinators
that we take care with
other people's data
and we do no harm.
So I'm going to turn
it over to Kiegan.
All right.
Can can you hear me?
Is my mic on?
Awesome. Thank you.
So the second principle
of how to be a pollinator
is to make things
that just work.
So what we really
mean by this is
we want to remove barriers
for either people interacting
with R or people
who are using things
that we're creating
in R to make it
so that things
just work for them.
So a good example of making
things that just work is
consider how your data
are being outputted.
So you might take the
usual approach of I'm
going to share this data that
I've cleaned and wrangled in
R. It's really awesome looking.
It's tidy.
I'm going to save
it out as a CSV.
So that's one approach.
If you think about who the
next user is going to be,
you could also take
a different approach.
And again, with one
line of code here,
using the foreign package,
we can write foreign
and include the command
package equals SAS
and that gives us a SAS script.
So now not only do we have the
CSV, but the next person who
uses this data, if they're
going to use it in SAS,
they have a script
that reads in the data
and adds the correct
formatting and labels for them
automatically.
So this is a really
great way to make sure
that the next person
has an easier time.
They go ahead and run this
script and the data just works.
They don't have to go
digging for the formatting
and the labels and
reencode everything
in a way that
makes sense to SAS.
It just works.
It's already there.
Another example is something
you've maybe run into a message
like, this looks like
there's a hiccup.
The server hosted
dashboard is not
filtering based on
the uploaded file,
but it's working on
my local computer.
So maybe you've gotten this
message, this panicked email.
Maybe you sent this panicked
email at some point.
It's working on one
computer, but it's not
working on another.
It's working on the server,
but it's not working locally.
So for somebody who's not
super confident in figuring out
what errors are going wrong,
this can be really scary.
This can be a way that
they're interacting
with R that they don't
know what is going wrong
and how to fix it.
So we can remove
this possible barrier
by, from the start, using
something like renv.
And there are a lot
of different options.
But essentially if you
don't know what renv is,
go look it up.
But it allows us to keep
track of the package versions
we're using when we're
writing and implementing code
and share those with any
other, any other people
or environments that we're
going to use this code on.
So the next time we
go to run this code,
it works on the server
and it works locally,
it works on your machine
and it works on my machine.
And when we come back to
this code in six months,
it runs exactly like
it's supposed to.
It just works.
So again, with a
little bit of effort
and a bit of empathy for
how other people are going
to be interacting with the
things you are creating in R,
you can build a positive
interaction, right?
A positive interaction
with R or something
you've created in R can kind
of smooth out those friction
points that people run
into and make things
that just work for people.
So the third principle
is to promote growth.
And we really want to bring as
many people into the R fold
and into the R community at
our organization as possible.
And so we do this
in a couple of ways.
The first that we
do pretty often
is have newer R users interact
with existing scripts
and processes.
So maybe a more advanced.
R user is going to write a
script or some sort of process
to complete a task.
Maybe it's a data
analytics, data analysis,
maybe it creates a table,
maybe it creates a chart,
and we can have newer users
take that already written code
and run it with maybe
changes to certain functions,
certain parameters or
flags within that code.
And this may lead to
the following scenario.
You're trying to figure out what
exactly happened to the script
that you wrote.
So you ran lines 1
through 57, then you
changed overwrite to true, then
61 through 66, then back to 37.
And this can be a really
frustrating conversation
to have if for both
people, if you're
trying to figure out
exactly what happened
and exactly what went wrong.
And now the person interacting
with this code who's
maybe a newer R user
is going to feel
frustrated and a little scared.
So there's a couple of
ways that you can just
make this a little bit easier.
And provide a more
low risk way for them
to interact with this code.
So one is you can use a dialog
box, so something like the
svDialogs package, you can
write again one line of code
and you can have a user
go run an R script.
And when it gets
to a certain point
where you've inserted
this dialog box code,
a dialog box will
pop up and give them
the option to select Yes or No.
So maybe it's whether
you're going to include
a certain set of NAs or not.
Maybe it's whether
you're going to run
this for males or females,
whatever it is that it's
a much easier way for them
to interact with the code,
and it's much less
likely that you're
going to run into this tracking
down what lines of code
got run, at what
time and what order.
So with a little
more effort, you
can also give them a more
user friendly interface
to interact with.
So here's an example
of a process where
we have analysts run dozens of
reports over a couple of months
each year, and we built a
Shiny dashboard for them.
So they can see what
reports need to be run.
There's some of this
metadata here redacted.
But how many reports
are left to run?
How many have already been run?
And they can select a
specific report in the table
and go to the details
of that report,
see all the metadata
that they need,
and see all these
action buttons that
let them take certain
steps in the process.
So the users are interacting
with buttons in this
without actually having
to run the code themselves
and they're able to see
exactly the products of this.
These beautiful created
R Markdown documents
without having to run the code
themselves or dig into it.
So a good example of how
this can promote growth
is we had an analyst
start and say, hey,
I'm honestly not
sure what happened.
I caused this error.
I thought I did
everything right.
So I dug into it, figured
out the error fix,
fixed it and got back
to them and they said,
I'd really be interested
in what went wrong.
I really want to get
better at using R. So
I explained the process
and what went wrong
and why it was fixed now.
Cut to a few weeks later.
And I get the following message
after they hit an error.
I'm looking at
the log right now.
So far I only see
warnings, but I'm
going to go look for the error.
So now, within the
span of about a month,
this person went from not having
any idea how to figure out
what caused the error to
digging into the logs themselves
and trying to figure
out what the error was.
And really kind of
learning on their own
and trying to get better.
So with a little bit of empathy
and a little bit more effort,
maybe building out a
whole user interface,
we've provided people a learning
opportunity and a low risk
environment to see how powerful
R code can be and see
how it runs without having
to open the door to maybe
scary mistakes that they're
not sure how to fix.
So we can promote
growth in users who may
be interested in learning more.
So what we want to
leave you with today
is to think about
the question, how
can you pollinate your own
data workflows using R?
So can you do no harm?
Can you make things that
just work and can you
promote growth?
And I would posit that
you can, but thank you.
Thank you.
But think about how
you can be this
bee, right?
Think about how you can travel
between different environments
and work with different people.
And think about what you can
learn from having empathy
from the perspective
of others and think
about what positive impact
you can leave behind with you.
So thank you.